bon sens nous sommes le mardi 27 octobre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur
l'actualité locale entouré de nos
invités et deux journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite
on commence avec les titres de cette
édition les six sont chercheurs de
l'inria l'institut national de recherche
en informatique et en automatique
installé à au concours depuis 1967
s'apprêtent à faire leurs valises pour
paris un déménagement que n'apprécie pas
les élus locaux les explications à
suivre les 6 et 13 décembre se
dérouleront les élections régionales la
campagne officielle débute les candidats
déclarent en ile de france
leur programme nous ferons le point dans
cette édition et enfin night phare un
thriller survival produits à l'aide du
cross-selling qui était tourné à saint
quentin en yvelines s'est signée julien
seri il nous en parlera en plateau dans
quelques instants sortie programmée le
13 janvier et pour ouvrir à cette
édition les chiffres du chômage ils ont
été communiqués hier pour le mois de
septembre dans le département le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi de la catégorie a
c'est à dire ceux qui n'exercent aucune
activité a reculé de 1 4% au mois de
septembre il y aurait 8 190 chômeurs de
moins inscrits à pôle emploi qu'au mois
d'août dans les yvelines une légère
amélioration mais sur un an le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi de la catégorie a a
augmenté de 2,8 pour cent toutes
catégories confondues le nombre de
chômeurs s'établit à 90 1790 inscrits
dans les yvelines
un chiffre stable par rapport au mois
d'août mais en hausse de 5,3 pour cent
sur l'année et cet après midi en gare de
versailles chantiers se tenait un
meeting public d'information syndicale
organisée par la cgt cheminots de
versailles rejoint exceptionnellement
par des représentants de syndicats
étrangers chypriote et portugais les
syndicalistes ont abordé les élections
professionnelles à la sncf mais
également leurs revendications
concernant les récentes suppressions de
postes et fermetures de ligne on écoute
les précisions de mathieu ball et reda
au micro de william el est ce que ça
nous a permis de les changer
allianz d'échanger les analyses on voit
que la situation est partout la même
c'est à dire que partout on attaque les
services publics on attaque les
conditions de travail des travailleurs
on casse les conventions collectives
partout au nom de la libre concurrence
la concurrence libre et non faussée
l'union européenne est donc partout il
ya des réactions il ya des luttes et des
résistances et parfois même des
victoires je prends l'exemple au
portugal la compagnie ferroviaire elle
est encore unique et encore intégré et
elle est encore dispose encore du
monopole public ferroviaire sur le
transport de marchandises et de
voyageurs rapport nous résister c'est
exister et on peut continuer à se battre
et gagner et gagner dans ce pays un
service public ferroviaire de qualité
aux mobilisations à présent hier après
midi une cinquantaine d'avocats se sont
rassemblés devant le tribunal de grande
instance de versailles pour protester
contre la réforme de l'aide
juridictionnelle prévu par le
gouvernement
cet appel à la grève a été lancé par le
conseil de l'ordre du barreau de
versailles qui exige le retrait des
mesures actuelles
il demande aux pouvoirs publics de
procéder à une véritable réforme du
financement de l'aide juridictionnelle
une réponse de la garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice christiane
taubira est attendu dès cette semaine
frédéric landon bâtonnier de l'ordre
envisage de durcir le mouvement s'ils
n'obtiennent pas satisfaction
on les écoute et micro de camille
lambert nous faisons grève jusqu'à
mercredi prochain fin de journée et
s'ils ne vont pas les propositions
sérieuses et concrètes on va poursuivre
ce mouvement et le durcir
l'objectif il est très clair soit on
nous donne satisfaction parce que nos
propositions sont justes et raisonnables
soient ne donne pas satisfaction il en
ira jusqu'à bloquer le fonctionnement de
la justice dans ce pays
il faudra qu'un jour l'état mette de
l'argent pour la justice notamment le
jury sionnel et aurait été ce combat on
le mène pour 9 millions de nos
concitoyens qui ne peuvent accéder au
droit et à la justice par leurs propres
moyens financiers l'inria est l'institut
national de recherche dédié au numérique
installé à un concours depuis 1967 va
bientôt déménager à paris le siège
social restera dans la commune mais 300
chercheurs seraient concernés par ce
départ qui devrait être terminée d'ici
la fin du mois de janvier la nouvelle
elle n'est pas très bien reçu par les
élus locaux
william el est patrick jacques de
dixmude c'est un projet prévu depuis
2007 qui s'est accéléré ces dernières
semaines avant la fin du mois
de janvier l'ensemble des services de
support à la recherche quitteront les
locaux de l'inria à rocquencourt pour le
site de paris l'objectif rassemblé
étudiants et chercheurs sur le même
périmètre
nos chercheurs travaillent dans des
équipes de recherche en lien avec les
partenaires académiques et en
particulier avec beaucoup d'étudiants
dans les équipes
nous avons cherché un nouveau site bien
évidemment pour nous rapprocher de nos
partenaires comme je viens de vous
l'indiquer mais également pour dans un
premier temps simplement pour essayer de
se rapprocher les transports en commun
et donc nous avons étudié de nombreuses
possibilités dans les yvelines
aucune n'a abouti c'est finalement place
d'italie à paris que les 300 chercheurs
concernés s'installeront un déménagement
assez mal reçue du côté des élus locaux
nous n'avons pas du tout été associé au
déroulement de l'histoire
on apprend un petit peu par hasard que
l'inria kit concours pour paris à
l'époque c'était en 2007
des gros ce n'est des promesses très
importante avait été fait à part le
conseil général à l'inria pour les
maintenir sur place rénover les
bâtiments et garder cette attitude
prestige dans les yvelines le conseil
départemental et versailles grand parc
compte tout mettre en oeuvre pour
conserver le siège social qui pour
l'instant restent sur le site de
rocquencourt avec ses 120 employés
l'antenne de sa clé n'étant pas
concernés par ce déménagement in rien ne
quitte en aucun cas le plateau et le
projet de saclay il y a une grosse
partie de la recherche académique qui se
fait dans la région française qui sait
dans la région de france et dans nos
domaines il y a deux très gros pôles
d'attractivité qui sont à la fois
plateau de saclay et puis le centre de
paris et donc inria a décidé d'avoir
deux de ses 8 centres de recherche dans
la région de france avec ce départ sept
hectares seront libérés par l'institut
le transfert devrait être terminée d'ici
la fin du mois de janvier et depuis
lundi nous sommes entrés dans la
campagne officielle des régionales
aujourd'hui nous faisons le point dans
ce journal sur les candidats qui se
présentent en ile-de-france ben sahar et
freedom en soi un flora nous allons
faire le point également sur leur
programme assez différents candidats
maintenant un peu moins de six semaines
du premier tour avec tout de même une
précision les listes n'ont pas encore
été déposés en préfecture elle
pouvoir évoluer des fusions des nouveaux
noms cela semble assez peu probable
quelques abandons en revanche c'est plus
envisageable il y as en ile de france
209 conseillers à élire rappelons le les
élections régionales
c'est un scrutin de liste comme pour les
municipales et en ile-de-france convient
de liste se sont manifestés à ce jour
onze listes voici le tableau
récapitulatif avant de rentrer dans le
détail on retrouve claude bartolone
valérie pécresse valeron de saint-just
europe écologie et les verts le front de
gauche se présente seul pas d'alliance
donc puis viennent ensuite un peu plus
loin les listes menées par aurélien
véron pour le parti libéral et démocrate
ou encore françois asselineau pour
l'union populaire républicaine des
listes qui plafonnerait à moins de 1%
seulement selon les sondages de ces
derniers jours et si l'on en croit ces
sondages justement elle c'est valérie
pécresse qui pourrait à l'emporter face
à claude bartolone dans le cadre d'une
triangulaire avec vallerand de
saint-just crédité lui de 20%
d'intentions de vote
on rappelle que pour se qualifier au
second tour il faut faire plus de 10%
des voix et 5% pour pouvoir fusionner
son côté programme à présent bien sûr je
vais pas vous résumer l'intégralité des
propositions des candidats en quelques
minutes on va juste dégagé et quelques
grandes lignes du côté de la droite du
centre droit valérie pécresse mise
beaucoup sur le transport cela fait plus
d'un an qu'elle est en campagne elle
était d'ailleurs déjà candidate lors des
précédentes élections
elle propose par exemple 2500 places
près des gares dans les yvelines des
places gratuites pour les utilisateurs
du passe navigo ou encore est des lignes
de bus en site propre pourquoi pas à
saint quentin en yvelines entre eux
magny les hameaux et saclay mais ça
n'est pas sa seule priorité elle parle
également d'emplois
le grand combat de la région c'est la
lutte contre le chômage on dit
mes adversaires ont dit à 200 millions
de budget pour le développement
économique c'est pas vrai la région à 5
milliards de budget et dans son budget
elle fait des transports de la formation
des lycées de l'université de la
recherche
tout ça ça doit être mis au service la
création d'emplois c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit que je voulais être un
président entrepreneurs qui va aller
créer de la richesse chercher les
investisseurs cherchent et les crédits
européens et que la région sera pro
entreprise la région est détenu par les
socialistes depuis 17 ans mais ça n'est
pas jean paul huchon le président
sortant qui va défendre les couleurs de
sa formation c'est le président du
perchoir claude bartolone qui très bien
la tête de l'assemblée nationale pour
celle de l'île de france et pour
convaincre les électeurs il défend le
bilan de son prédécesseur et propose
aussi par exemple de bloquer les
augmentations de la fiscalité régionale
pour les contribuables et les
entreprises ou encore de déployer
l'encadrement des loyers dans toute la
région il propose aussi une prime
régionale à la casse pour les
propriétaires d'un véhicule
professionnel ou utilitaires et diesel
selon son principal handicap sénat pas
avoir réussit l'alliance à gauche on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure ses anciens
partenaires qui sont d'ailleurs assez
sévères d'europe écologie les verts au
front de gauche pour pierre laurent le
responsable du parti communiste la
région dépense trop et le mal le gros
problème de cette région c'est qu'elle
est une région riche mais / les
inégalités et qu'il faut rééquilibrer
très profondément à son développement en
mettant la priorité sur la réponse aux
besoins sociaux des franciliens le
logement les transports
je crois qu'il ya quelque chose de neuf
à dire c'est surtout sur la manière dont
on peut financer autrement tout là tous
ses besoins en allant chercher des
recettes du côté des banques et du côté
de la richesse des entreprises qui est
aujourd'hui mal utilisé parfois même
aussi les fonds publics qui le sont mal
maîtriser les dépenses c'est aussi ce
que l'on retrouve du côté du front
national la formation d'extrême droite
va réaliser si l'on en croit les
différents et éditorialiste un score
sans précédent il faut dire
qu'aujourd'hui le parti de marine le pen
n'a aucun élu dans l'assemblée
francilienne je commence par une baisse
de la masse des dépenses de la région de
2% par an sur toute la mandature
certaines questions principe de choix
politiques une question symbolique en
fait question symbolique qui aboutirent
à 180 millions d'euros de baisses de
dépenses et en recettes baisses de
dépenses pourra participer d'une baisse
de la fiscalité et pourra par ailleurs
être rien réorientés vers d'autres
dépenses de la région que nous
souhaitons favoriser par rapport à ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui
reste que pour progresser encore dans
les sondages le front national doit
aussi compter avec nicolas dupont aignan
debout la france qui flirte avec les 10%
d'intentions de vote et des idées a
parfois très proches écouter d'ailleurs
à la position de ce dernier sur le grand
paris
le problème de fond de la région c'est
que c'est la région la plus prospère de
france où l'on vit le moins bien et ça
ça peut pas durer donc il faut à mon
avis que la région se concentre sur ses
compétences et règles problème des
transports
c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs je suis
hostile au projet fou du grand paris et
je veux qu'on entretienne et qu'on
rénove les transports déjà existants et
c'est pourquoi aussi je crois que la
liste des usagers s'est rallié à ma
liste
vous venez d'entendre quelques uns des
onze candidats qui se présentent en
ile-de-france bien sûr ils vont tous
s'exprimer sur cette antenne d'ici le
premier tour du 6 décembre dans un
respect de l'équité comme le recommande
le csa depuis voilà pour l'essentiel de
la campagne des régionales et pour un
point plus complet donc le cetud
politique le mardi à 18h30 en direct et
pour cette édition du 27 octobre je
recevrai françois asselineau le
président de l'upm la tête de liste dans
notre région merci wilfried et
l'association trappe actions solidaires
organisent de nombreuses collectes
fournitures scolaires vêtements ou
encore denrées alimentaires créé il ya
seulement un mois et demi son but est de
venir en aide aux familles démunies de
la ville
samedi elle était présente au centre
commercial des muses riziers pour faire
appel à la générosité des trappistes
fanny bourdillon elodie moines des
boîtes de conserve des sacs de riz des
produits d'hygiène peu à peu les cartons
de l'association trappe action solidaire
se remplissent devant ce supermarché de
la ville moustafa ben lahcen le
président de cette toute nouvelle
association a grandi dans un quartier
hlm de trappes
il veut venir en aide aux familles les
plus démunies de la ville
on essaie de faire en sorte que les
habitants trappe aide les familles de
trappes
donc en gros nous sommes juste un
intermédiaire nous redistribuons ces
aliments à des familles qui sont dans
une très très grande qualité
nous distribuons des prospectus en
expliquant nos actions sachant que
l'avantagé qu'on demande des dons mais
aussi on explique les actions que nous
menons et on demande beaucoup de
produits alimentaires tels que les pâtes
le riz l'huile des gâteaux du lait tout
ce qui est dangereux non périssables les
bénévoles tous trappistes distribuer des
prospectus aux clients du magasin
si certains ressortent sans s'arrêter
pour d'autres c'est un geste tout à fait
normal
ma faut aider les autres tout simplement
nous on a tous et ils ont rien c'est un
geste pour l'humanité mais normalement
et tous des humains on doit un délai à
un autre j'avais un chariot et vaches
les remplit c'est la moindre des choses
j'ai partagé mes courses en deux créé il
ya moins de deux mois
trappes action solidaire accompagne déjà
une centaine de familles et il est temps
de parler cinéma à présent nous recevons
ce soir en plateau julien seri bonsoir
et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
alors vous êtes le fondateur de la
société d'agro film vous avez en grande
partie est écrit et réalisé yamakasi les
fils du vent ou encore scorpions avaient
clovis cornillac vous êtes ici pour nous
parler de votre fils knight phare qui
est sortie en avant première hier
alors si je résume l'histoire c'est
l'histoire de deux amis qui rentrent en
taxi de paris en soi et décide de faire
un taxi basket dont de ne pas payer la
course mais le chauffeur lui va les
poursuivre et pas forcément pour
l'argent on en parle tout de suite après
cet extrait
lloris
quant à nokia i'm gonna give you up se
passe comme en 2006
vous pouvez visiter
restée très bien monsieur va descendre
là donc merci pour la course mais
revient venu mon grand-père de pékin
non non non
casser les couilles pour cinq ans malgré
votre quand ça arrive et de maghazi
dégâts à la stature qui rêve a bien
cherché
alors julien serré nous l'avons vu c'est
à film d'action mais c'est aussi un peu
un film d'auteur il a été tourné en
seulement quelques semaines à saint
quentin en yvelines
oui on a tourné en le premier tour 9
voitures et trois semaines sur saint
quentin et puis un mois après la fin du
tournage j'ai décidé de repartir en
anjou t on la retourne une petite
semaine en contre on a du temps des 24
jours comment on fait pour tourner un
film aussi rapidement eh ben je crois
que je ne sais toujours pas comment tu
as on n'avait pas le choix donc on avait
un petit budget on n'a pas beaucoup de
temps il fallait évidemment respecter le
planning les délais et puis on a tourné
au mois d'août parce qu'on savait qu'on
allait mettre les enfants en vacances et
donc il fallait qu'on finisse fin août
parce que début septembre c'est la
rentrée des classes et c'était facile
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de cinéastes
français qui ne veulent pas tourner en
france qui s'exilent un peu jeunes
comprennent impôts vous avez des
facilités à tourner les cja 50 ans des
films on a eu des facilités oui parce
que la vie nous a superbement accueillis
on a vraiment été aidé par par toute la
commune donc on n'a pas une aide
financière mais on a eu une aide
logistique et justement qu'est-ce qui
vous a plu pour vous avez choisi
justement ce territoire pour tourner
alors on a choisi saint quentin en fait
paul mignot l'un des coproducteurs a
grandi ici et sa maman vit encore ici
chantal mignot est donc un soir paul me
dis mais qu'est ce que tu me racontes du
film faust au yen à saint quentin
donc on est venus en repérage une nuit
et j'ai trouvé la ville assez incroyable
visuellement très très riche avec des
décors déjà mis en lumière ce qui pour
un petit budget comme moi ne pas avoir à
ré éclairer toute la ville c'était
grande aide alors voilà l'idée du film
donc lui aussi est donc le seul
chauffeur de taxi c'est un ancien un
ancien j'espère comme on dit deux
combattants de mma
ouais voilà la c1 anciens combattants de
l'ufc la fameuse organisation
c'est un de nos plus grands champions
français jess chiodin et j'ai tout de
suite pensé pensé à lui quand j'ai
visualisé driver cet homme un peu un peu
difficile
et l'idée du film vous avez comment en
fait un ami à moi qui s'appelle karoubi
ya quelques années il
trois ans il m'a raconté une de ces
soirées il est rentré chez lui et a fait
un taxi basket et le driver ne l'a pas
lâché toute la nuit et quand il m'a
raconté ça je me suis dit mais c'est
vrai que ça ferait une super idée pour
un pour un film de genre efficace et et
et dynamique alors justement c'est un
projet spécial aussi parce que vous
l'avez tourné en quelques semaines il a
été financé par des fonds privés sur la
plateforme hull
c'était voilà c'était une idée commencer
et commencer un petit peu venu ça reste
et dont l'idée de faire un dîner mais
très rapidement
oui en fait moi ça faisait huit ans
entre entremont précédents films
scorpions et et night faire ça faisait
huit ans que j'avais pas réussi à monter
un film donc j'étais vraiment sur le
point d'arrêter ce métier et quand j'en
ai parlé à pascal sid épaule mignot de d
co producteur ils m'ont dit qu'ils
n'étaient pas vraiment d'accord avec
cette idée que j'arrête se sont ils ont
été ils ont travaillé ont démarré avec
moi mon métier et ils m'ont proposé un
deal moins dix ans on part en vacances
on fait un film
donc il a fallu qu en trois mois on
écrive on caste on finance et en tourner
un film alors normalement un film ça
mais trois ans à se faire donc en fait
on a décidé de financer le film
autrement que par les structures
habituelles
donc on a trouvé de l'argent des fonds
privés et on a aussi utilisé ulule au
départ et lula était surtout choisi dans
le dans l'idée de créer une famille
autour du film espèce de communauté de
2,2 de fans et personnes motivées on
savait qu'ils allaient nous aider à
communiquer autour du film mais quand on
a lancé le film on n'avait aucune
garantie que le film allait sortir on et
puis le film dérange déranger un peu
puisque c'était drame c'est un vrai film
indépendant quoi qu'on a fait sans
l'aide de personne
c'est vraiment votre fan base un peu si
on peut dire est qu'elles participent et
voilà au film fut vraiment il ya des
gens à des autres peut-être cet auteur
ou du monde du cinéma qui sont dit ben
voilà on s'implique parce qu'on veut que
je viens serré continuer à faire des
films
alors c'est vrai que j'ai ma fanbase
entre guillemets qui était vraiment
présente mais c'est vrai que j'ai aussi
reçu l'aide de grands metteurs en scène
comme jean françois richet me mathieu
kassovitz jan kounen bruno aveillan
xavier gens se fait cavalier florent
emilio siri et plein d'autres frais de
délits et plein d'autres qui m'ont tous
soutenus dans la démarche dans cette
démarche de cinéma en fait ils m'ont dit
c'est la première fois je pense que
c'est assez historique que autant de
metteur en scène
deux entre guillemets meilleur que moi
meilleur qu'un metteur en scène viennent
le soutenir pour faire son film et même
certains ont même mis de l'argent dans
un film c'est aujourd'hui vraiment une
nouvelle façon de faire du cinéma
le financement privé français savaient
que je vais développer en tout cas moi
j'ai pu faire ce film grâce à ça je
pense que ça va je pense que ça va se
démocratiser parce que je pense aussi
c'est vrai que quand on veut faire un
cinéma différent quand on veut faire des
propositions de cinéma d'un film un peu
plus singuliers ça devient plus
difficile aujourd'hui de d'avoir les
aides de l'état et d'avoir les aides des
chaînes de télé c'est possible
évidemment et je pense qu'on a envie de
faire
on a la chance d'avoir trouvé un
distributeur sur le film en salles
d'avoir déjà pays devant d'une film dans
plus de 20 pays
donc on se le film est très très bien
accueilli on a déjà gagné un festival
aux états unis on a repris le prix du
meilleur film au festival de denver ont
la 19e festival au compteur déjà en
quelques mois donc je pense que tout
d'un coup ça j'espère que ce film va
pouvoir prouver aussi au métier qu'on
peut faire un cinéma un peu plus
différent un peu plus singulier mais qui
intéresse le public évidemment
pourtant alors votre fils arrêté voilà
vous l'avez deviné des nombreux
festivals 19 qui a été salué par la
critique pourtant ça vous décaler la
date de sortie alors hier c'était
l'avant première mais le film sortira le
13 janvier pourquoi alors pourquoi
évidemment c'était pas prévu on a mis du
temps à prendre cette décision mais en
fait il s'avère que aujourd'hui trois
films tiennent la moitié du marché il ya
à peu près six mille 6500 écrans en
france et trois films tracks et aladdin
transylvania est seul sur mars qui
détiennent à eux trois 3000 écrans
donc on a bien compris que de façon pour
un petit film comme nous ça allait être
difficile de combattre
et puis évidemment la semaine prochaine
est de l'île ronde qui sort et puis
après il ya un gars games et puis après
donc on s'est dit bon
bien être courageux mais pas kamikaze on
veut pas on veut pas tuer le film comme
ça et on veut lui donner un maximum de
chances pour qu'il touche son public on
va bénéficier de trois mois
supplémentaires avant que les films
sortent donc on va pouvoir faire plus
d'avant premières et beaucoup plus
communiquer sur les réseaux sociaux et
et sur tout un axe de communication un
peu plus haut lui aussi qui sera un peu
plus singulier parce qu'on n'a pas
évidemment pas les moyens de communiquer
comme toutes ces grosses productions
alors night phare ça sort le 13 janvier
2016 on espère qu'il sera vivant tout
cas dans les salles de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines compromis eh
bien peut-être nouvelle fois grand merci
beaucoup julien seri d'être venu avec
nous et plusieurs films aussi lui ont
été consacrés ainsi qu'à son procès
c'est celui du tueur en série américain
ted bundy
les associés les étudiants de
l'association juris tribune de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines ont reconstitué son procès
vendredi dernier au tribunal de grande
instance de versailles
nous y étions regarder novembre 1977
c'est à ce moment que s'ouvre le procès
de ted bundy
ted bundy c'est un des tueurs en série
les plus connus des états unis il aurait
assassiné environ 30 victimes entre 1973
et 1978 dans plusieurs états et c'est ce
procès que les étudiants de
l'association juris tribune de
l'université de droit de saint quentin
en yvelines ont choisi de rejouer au
tribunal de grande instance de
versailles
c'est quelqu'un qui avait beaucoup
d'entregent qui avait beaucoup de
capacités en fait de raisonnement et il
a décidé comme ça peut arriver dans un
cas réel et compris en france de se
défendre tout seul
étudiants et professeurs chacun s'est
plongé dans son rôle
c'est yacine qui en charge de rejouer le
tueur en série
si ted bundy a été condamné à la peine
de mort aujourd'hui l'issue pourrait
être différente pour le jeune étudiant
en droit le droit de la preuve
c'est là que j'ai vraiment beaucoup
travaillé parce que
c'est vrai que les preuves qui sont
assez accablantes mais on verrait pas
lent procès il peut y avoir des failles
et j'ai beaucoup travaillé là dessus
après sur aussi l'art est fait
l'interprétation est l'interrogation des
témoins une approche concrète du droit
pour ces étudiants qui pour la plupart
n'ont jamais assisté à un procès pas
d'obligation d'y participer l'initiative
vient des étudiants elle n'est pas
inscrit dans leur programme mais
représente un intérêt pédagogique
la plus value c'est évidemment donc de
pouvoir donc se lancer dans un autre
type de procès avec des procédures est
un droit complètement différent puisque
c'est le le droit américain donc je
pense que ça peut aussi leur donner une
vue un petit peu différente de ce qu'est
la justice comme en 1977 le procès très
médiatique qui à l'époque a aussi fait
salle comble le ted bundy versailles et
a réussi cette fois échappé à la peine
de mort mais pas à la prison le jury
d'étudiants plus clément l'a condamné à
30 ans de réclusion
et c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis tout de
suite vous avez rendez vous avec wilfrid
est réussi et ses invités pour le 7-8
politique pour ma part je vous retrouve
demain à 18 heures pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée
oui